welcome to my kingdom marzia thank you
these are my humble servant I love them
so this is Danny this is Danny today
we're gonna switch it up we can sleep
yeah we never played this before but it
looks pretty fun way to draw anything
okay so it's just a tutorial you're
calling it interface he's playing finger
the finger that lower your guns with the
muzzle facing the ground you're going
bad girl face you ready to die yeah
y'all ready don't care what these yeah I
love you bye jet plane food it and why
did you why did you do this farm yes
you're doing good
yeah
[Music]
quick girl what are you putting it
except you won't hit my favorite man you
go die a girl from now walking to punt
what are you watching the doctor what's
happening I don't know
oh we haven't started what's happening I
don't know
[Music]
I sent you in the face ah ah I can use
you did oh how whatever it's one one son
comment you can ask yourself question do
I feel lucky and you better than me
lower your gun
that is each other let's do you punk
come on I definitely got that one
dad what did you say samurai we want to
do two samurai so literally yeah what
the 1/2 doctor word on the other I have
to catch two sort what that's gonna hurt
that's definitely gonna hurt me
dart so what do you do to come a happy
Oh lips winged up alright you did swing
a dark uh-huh why would you hurt me
[Music]
please don't hurt me wait Dart
oh wow wow wow you did a delicious how
do I win I'm too good it's the sweetest
blood we're so good at table tennis know
what I'm bad eating you - why am i
winning then why why am i was daddy's
are cheering for me now Wow
[Applause]
they're Italian real life I would have
to say well if it's jamming what are you
go away I can't move ah [ __ ] you looking
at old man what did we do with migraine
face each other okay on your mark
okay
well start good job right
oh very late I don't want to exercise
someone no result
[Music]
no I got it
Oh beautiful
yeah yeah got them yeah Danny DeVito's
gone crazy mindful your surroundings and
stand far enough apart so you don't bump
into away or you die we're gonna gather
this just today don't fully engage ready
attack don't you find some common no
we're not putting alright we will fight
for real now face each other and get
ready
Ryan punch best it is your opponent I
put my that's right look oh great
ha ha ha what right I forgot what is
happening
ah what did I say said don't hit me
[Music]
what great okay why'd you stop hitting
me
right oh look okay fine Oh crackling
fire my you may not see my game CD and
yeah you should talk to Nintendo about
that oh my God look at your hands you
milk oh shut up damn blazing like don't
forget to lose nipple Huntress oh damn
are they little vanity how do you get
stuck all then how did you get so much
milk you ready to shave girl you ready
to shave this is the ultimate now and
test the first player to shave off their
entire beard win it we got back plenty
wait wait whoa whoa what is happening
here Oh were you oh my god and so
inaccurate and unconscious oh oh yeah
you look good you're gonna fall
[Applause]
[Music]
what do you good job might be out you
did great today
thank you for losing you lost how to
build what are you gonna say it's
everyone tell that I love you like and
what I want so many of this molecule
again I will leave it to the comments
Yahoo what one day that mean try to make
fun of me no they've got a little
watching them lack of you Jordan is
always nerves Deborah Robert
BAM round